est omniprésente dans l'éducation de
Louis XIV il n'en va pas de même pour
son fils cadet Philippe que tout le
monde appelle monsieur en effet la reine
va donner à ses enfants deux éducations
totalement différentes
c'est vrai que Philippe je l'ai éduqué
différemment c'est un enfant sensible
doux avec une certaine féminité il est à
l'opposé de son frère
la reine aime ses deux enfants
évidemment le petit Louis et le petit
Philippe mais naturellement avec une
préférence pour l'aîné celui qui est
appelé apporté la couronne
toute la tension de la reine se porte
donc sur Louis XIV au détriment bien sûr
de son fils cadet Philippe je pense que
le malheureux monsieur a été quelque peu
mis sur la touche qu'il était quelque
peu délaissé il était tout simplement ce
qu'on appelle la roue de secours c'est
terrible d'être une roue de secours et
je pense d'ailleurs que l'éducation
n'était pas la même l'un a reçu
l'éducation d'un roi l'autre n'a reçu
que l'éducation d'un second il y a une
jalousie qui s'instore les deux enfants
sont élevés ensemble en même temps ce
sont des rivaux sciemment et des tout
petits on va écarter et déres
sensibiliser Philippe le jeune frère du
roi il va développer donc une
personnalité un peu atypique assez
immature capricieuse il aimera se farder
et qu'il s'attachera beaucoup du
meilleur très précieuse à son
habillement en effet des sons plus jeune
âge Philippe le frère du roi aime se
travestir il ne se résout pas abandonner
les robes qu'il portait enfant ce qui ne
sera pas anodin
du question aura une incidence
incroyable sur la vie voir la sexualité
là Louis XIV est un homme qui a un
appétit incroyable et un goût des femmes
démesurées monsieur est un homme
beaucoup plus fêtard que Louis XIV et
qui lui s'apportera davantage sur
l'homosexualité et cela Louis XIV ne va
pas le supporter
je ne peux plus vous voir derrière les
portes avec des garçons pour vos
débauches cachez vous
ou derrière les portes avec les filles
petites tes prières
[Musique]
deux garçons une même maman une
éducation totalement différente à l'un
pour l'autre de parcours différents
il sera donc capable d'assurer la
descendance du royaume elle peut à
présent veiller à l'éducation politique
de son fils afin qu'il devienne un grand
roi Anne d'Autriche continuera à
gouverner la France pendant encore
quelques années en compagnie du cardinal
Mazarin Premier ministre du royaume en
attendant Louis apprend son métier de
roi mais il ne va pas tarder à
comprendre qu'un souverain aussi
puissant soit-il ne fait pas toujours ce
qu'il veut
nous sommes en 1658 Louis XIV a 20 ans
c'est un beau jeune homme et il va pour
la première fois de sa vie tombée
amoureux
à cette époque la France est en guerre
en vue d'annexer le territoire de la
Flandre qui appartient pour le moment
aux Espagnols
[Musique]
ce soir-là le cardinal Mazarin est
inquiet alors que les combats font rage
Louis XIV est tombé gravement malade les
médecins diagnostiquent une fièvre
typhoïde comment vous sentez-vous aussi
alors il tombe malade c'est une grande
inquiétude à Paris au prix pour le la
santé du roi et alors que Louis XIV
tremble de fièvre le coup de foudre va
se produire
[Musique]
là il tombe sous le charme de qui et
bien de la fameuse petite Marie
manuccini
[Musique]
Mazarin a fait venir d'Italie toute sa
tribu de nièce toutes les petites
mazzarinettes qui étaient de jolis
petites femmes d'ailleurs la petite
Marie Mancini était peut-être la plus
mignonne en effet le cheveu très noir
l’œil très vif très fine traite presque
maigre d'ailleurs on dit qu'elle avait
des tables de Héron tellement ses jambes
étaient lancés et Louis XIV la rencontre
croise son regard il tombe sous le